ancient greece was not even a cohesive
empire was made up of many city-states
led by athens and sparta but despite its
fragmentation it's made innumerable
contributions to not just western
civilization but civilization as a whole
and those are contributions in terms of
forms of governance like democracy
contributions in medicine contributions
in the arts in the in mathematics in the
sciences but perhaps their most famous
contribution is in terms of philosophy
and if you're going to talk about
philosophy in ancient greece the most
famous three philosophers are socrates
plato and aristotle now before we get
into
the first of them and really the teacher
of plato who is then the teacher of
aristotle let's get a little bit of
context on this time period
so as we enter into the 5th century bce
a couple of things are emerging
first you have a new athenian democracy
then as you get into that century
the persians invade try to conquer
greece several times but unsuccessfully
but then the greeks start fighting
amongst themselves led on one side by
athens and on the other side by sparta
and that's the peloponnesian war which
ends with sparta being victorious but
all of the greek city-states being
weakened dramatically
now between
the end especially the first part of the
greco-persian wars and the end of the
peloponnesian war it was actually a time
of athenian prosperity they were leading
this semi-empire they were investing in
the arts and it's often called the
golden age of athens and that's the
world in which socrates
emerged
like many philosophers socrates led a
very interesting life and it's worth
noting what we know about him does not
come directly from his writing we don't
have surviving accounts of his writing
it comes mainly through the writing of
his students xenophon and most notably
plato we also get some parody of
socrates from aristophanes that socrates
himself did not appreciate much
but what we know is that he started in
life he was a stonemason he even acted
as a soldier a hoplite during the
peloponnesian war but he's of course
most famous for being a philosopher and
for being a teacher and his teaching
style the socratic method is still
viewed as something of a best practice
today rather than lecturing students to
instead ask incisive questions that
force a student to deepen their thinking
and get closer to the root of an issue
and to learn how to think rather than
just having knowledge transmitted to
them
now what's also notable about socrates
and his many students including plato
and aristotle
is that they took a departure of how to
think about the world from most of the
ancient world most of the ancient world
was focused on the gods and the
metaphysical explaining everything and
while the ancient greeks did have a
large pantheon of gods socrates and his
fellow philosophers
tried to figure out how the world works
why we are here somewhat independent of
the gods they tried to reason it through
they tried to talk it through think
about it from a rational point of view
and to get a flavor of that here is a
quote
true wisdom comes to each of us when we
realize how little we understand about
life ourselves and the world around us
so unlike many ancient societies that
just tried to explain everything through
the metaphysical or through the gods
here you have socrates saying no an
ideal true wisdom
is when you appreciate how little we
know this form of intellectual humility
now socrates
lived during this golden age of athens a
time when democracy was flourishing the
age of pericles but he himself was a
little bit skeptical of unfettered or
pure democracy he was worried well what
if the people voting aren't educated to
make the types of decisions maybe they
can be manipulated by a demagogue
someone who just tells them exactly what
they want to hear
and so he was a bit of a controversial
figure especially as you get to the end
of the peloponnesian war remember athens
loses the peloponnesian war it went from
being this powerful head of this delian
league something of an empire this
wealthy city and now it's a subjugated
state it's tired from war and so you can
imagine there's a lot of political
infighting and socrates ends up being
one of the casualties he is actually put
on trial by his fellow athenians
this is a depiction of the trial of
socrates and it shows socrates defending
himself from the accusations brought
against him
refusing to recognize the gods
acknowledged by the state
importing strange divinities of his own
corrupting the young
and his defense which both xenophon and
plato write about called an apology
he's bewildered he says where is all of
this coming from now it is true he did
not invoke the gods when he's trying to
explain the universe and yes he was
trying to teach the young to think but
by no means if you look at what he was
doing or at least our modern accounts
coming through plato and xenophon does
it seem like he was trying to undermine
the state in some way
but needless to say it comes to a vote
and maybe he's a victim of his own fears
of a pure democratic process but amongst
the 500 athenians voting 280 say that he
is guilty and 220 say that he is not
guilty
he's given a chance to think about what
his penalty should be and the charges at
least in the athenians minds were quite
serious but socrates famously says
an unexamined life is not worth living
and so even though many historians think
that he might have been able to get
exile if he asked for it
he was sentenced to death
and this is a painting done much much
later
of what that death of socrates might
have looked like but you should you see
here socrates about to or maybe he just
drank the hemlock which is the poison
which will kill him
so even though he had to die for these
pretty spurious allegations his legacy
lives on and it lives on most famously
in his student plato
now plato is famous for many things
there's this notion of a platonic ideal
form
that whether you're talking about a
circle or a ball or a dog or a chair
that there's an ideal form that is
independent of what your senses are
telling you or what the chair in front
of you might be that that's an imperfect
version of that ideal form the word
platonic in general you'll hear applied
to many different concepts some of the
meanings having changed over time
the other thing that plato is famous for
is the notion of an academy the place
where he taught his students was a
little field outside the
walls of athens named for the athenian
hero academos
and so it'd be that area became known as
plato's academy and ever since then
places of learning have often been
referred to as academies just like khan
academy
but plato was also concerned like his
teacher socrates with the nature of how
we should be ruled
there will be no end to the troubles of
states or indeed of humanity itself till
philosophers become rulers in this world
or till those we now call kings and
rulers really and truly become
philosophers and political power and
philosophy thus come into the same hands
so like socrates he's wary of how they
have been governed and remember we're
now after the period of the
peloponnesian war the city-states of
greece and especially athens have been
dramatically weakened so a lot of people
might be thinking including plato well
is there a better way to govern
ourselves
now plato's most famous student is
aristotle
and like his teacher aristotle is famous
for many things and explored many
dimensions of the universe
but he is probably most famous for being
the tutor of alexander the great when
alexander the great was young philip of
macedon alexander the great's father
as he conquers the weakened city-states
after the peloponnesian war he also
conquers aristotle's hometown of stegera
and he enslaves the population and so
when he goes to aristotle to tutor his
young son who ends up being called
alexander the great eventually
aristotle says okay my fee will be
free the people of my town.
his town is freed he tutors
a young alexander when alexander's in
his early teens and he also gets support
for a center of learning he creates a
lyseum which is his version of plato's
academy
and just like you saw with socrates and
you see with plato aristotle continued
this tradition of a focus on learning
and a humble acceptance of all that
there might be in the world this
rationality that we now see in modern
science that you didn't see from a lot
of the ancients who are focused on the
metaphysics and the gods
it is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thought without
accepting it
and i'll leave you there
but the big takeaway is
going from socrates to plato to
aristotle and there were many other
greek philosophers you have the seed of
what you could call modern rationality
roughly 2 000 years later you have the
european renaissance that starts
re-emerging many of these same ideas all
the way providing a bridge into the
enlightenment and now our modern
hopefully fairly rational view of the
world